choose your character can i have a trans
character please
maybe
[Music]
hey there everybody i am really excited
about today's video but before we can
get too far into it
i do need to tell you about this video
sponsor today's video is sponsored by
the forever home friends a book and
plushie business run by small youtuber
savvy writes books
forever home friends creates picture
books plushies toys merch and more
based on real rescue dogs and their
stories of getting adopted
each dog's collection comes with a
signed book a 12-inch plush dog
toys and accessories for that dog and a
customizable adoption certificate
each dog's book explores themes related
to social issues like adoption
prejudice self-confidence body image
bullying
and more all through a dog's perspective
and includes discussion questions at the
end
to spark conversations between kids and
parents teachers and students
or even you and your dog 10 of profits
from every purchase benefit animal
shelters
visit foreverhomefriends.com link down
in the description
to check out their collections and don't
forget to follow them on their social
media platforms
also linked below so be sure to check
out that link below it's definitely a
business worth your time
so i had the privilege to talk with
laura kate dale also known as laura k
buzz
she is a podcaster she is a youtuber she
is
a video game journalist she is an
author she does a lot and she has a
really extensive background in covering
video games and video game related
topics as well as
her own existence in lgbtq plus and
queer spaces
and through her expertise i was finally
able to have a conversation that i've
wanted to have for ages
but i just personally don't have the
background to have which is
the history and possibly the future
of representing trans characters in
video games
let's get to it so obviously
uh this is as as someone who has been
covering video games for a while and
as a trans person this has kind of
become a little bit
i don't want to say your area of
expertise but something that's sort of
been on your radar and you've been
a little bit more immersed in than i
have given that i
kind of stopped current gen gaming at
the ps3
yeah it's something that for better or
worse i've been aware of through my
career
yeah yeah it is one of those things like
and like i do actually enjoy being able
to talk about lgbtq plus representation
and things like that but at the same
time there's a part of me that feels
like
whenever certain things happen i'm like
people expect me to talk about that
yes yeah exactly like i enjoy talking
about the topic
when i can choose to talk about the
topic it's not so fun when it's like oh
that game i haven't played yet that i
didn't know anything about suddenly i've
got 30 people tweeting me
hey have you played this you might like
it for reasons to do with you
and like being like hey hey hey talk
we're not gonna say it's got an lgbt
character in it but play it
yeah yeah that that kind of
recommendations
are like god every single time jk
rowling's in the news i'm like are you
gonna talk about this i'm like
i probably am but i don't want to
someone put transphobia in their game
can you please subject yourself to that
to have opinions
oh god yeah uh but
um we are gonna at least try and focus a
little bit more on the history of
of what representation in games has
actually looked like up to this point
um because i it kind of extends back a
bit
farther than i think a lot of people
realize
in some capacity although in a weird way
some of it's
like arguable but i guess out of
curiosity
for yourself what was the first
character that you felt spoke to you not
just as a woman but like
spoke to your trans experience in a
video game
probably the first time that i was
properly aware of a trans character in a
video game
and that i felt some significance to
their um
representation was learning about
vivian in uh paper mario the thousand
year door
um i'm from the uk and in the uk version
of paper marion the thousand year door
vivian being a trans woman is completely
erased from that game's narrative um
same with the us version
yeah i believe it's like uh japan and
some european countries some european
countries had better translations than
others but
it was something that like i'd heard at
school as like a rumor around the time
i'd been playing that game of oh have
you heard
and i went and did some reading about it
because it was just uh i was very
curious
and even though
vivian in the the english version of
thousand jador is not presented in the
text as being a trans woman
there was something that made a lot of
sense about her as a trans character
from the story she was in
um not to get too deep in into the story
when mario meets vivian as a character
um
the whole plot line mario is going
through is his name has been stolen his
identity has been stolen
no one recognizes him for who he is and
it's this whole quest of trying to
reclaim identity and trying to be seen
for who you are
and there was something about reading
about this character being a trans woman
and being like oh of course you befriend
mario who's on his quest to have people
call him by his name and see him for who
he is
and that's what brings the two of you
closer together that
was really interesting and stuck with me
for a long time
i only played that game relatively
recently because i
i got commissioned to play it uh through
my patreon and i so i knew about that
going in
and it was so strange to play it and
realize like
this is actually without that context is
a fairly frivolous addition to the party
yeah there's very little that makes
sense about why vivian
would leave her sisters and specifically
join mario and team the people she's
supposed to be opposing
yeah without that context in there yeah
and it makes no sense why her sisters
treat her the way they do
without that as a background layer it
seems completely arbitrary
yeah it's it seems so integral to what
that
story was clearly meant to be about yeah
yeah that's that is that was really an
odd case and kind of speaks to
in some ways a lot of the inconsistency
especially about
earlier um trans representation where
what you got depended on the region
you got the game in yes and the
if something was removed it was often
removed
very very without much thought as to
what would be left in its place
it's like let's take out this trans
representation and not think about the
void it's created
you can usually see the stitches and go
like yes
something got i don't know what but
something's missing
yeah it's it's it's very strange
seeing seeing attempts to just pretend
that those plot lines never existed
yeah i for me it's funny i don't it's
harder for me to
to think of a video game character that
spoke to me on that specific level
because about the time that i was really
starting to come into my own
um gender fluidity and and identify
something other than
a cis male cross-dresser was about the
same time that i started backing off
gaming
so so i found a lot more strong
connections
in film and television and not as many
in video games
although in hindsight i was able to look
back and go that's why i always
gravitated towards the female characters
when that was an option
oh i mean okay that's that's definitely
a thing like around the time that i was
first coming out it was a lot of like
what if i just
played these mmos with a female
character and a female name and just
didn't correct anyone's assumptions
about that
and you know a lot of those kind of
things were happening
yeah it's like oh this was why i powered
through
street fighter uh two championship
edition with cami before anybody else
oh god right well that plus i really
liked her but when she turned the sprite
around
for the victory pose but that's that's
another thing
so for me actually because i'm old
i'm old enough to still have my original
nintendo up in the attic
i've still got the
manual for super mario brothers 2
that says birdo is a boy who thinks
he's a girl yeah which nintendo has
backpedaled hard on in the years since
then
which makes me think that initially it
was a
joke that they didn't realize people
would latch onto
they so as someone that sort of been out
of games at some points
they didn't backpedal as hard on this as
you may think or as immediately as you
may think
um there is a game released on the wii
in japan in 2008
called captain rainbow and
birdo is canonically trans in that game
and you have
you have an entire plot thread and i
have some
quibbles about this but the short
version is birdo is arrested for using a
women's bathroom and you have to go find
a sex toy in her house to prove that
she's female
it's yeah yeah right
this never got released in english
languages i can't imagine why not
no but it you know that there are some
obvious issues with equating sex toy use
to
equals woman but a lot of people don't
realize that like as
as within the last 15 years nintendo
still were acknowledging
trans birdo is a thing that's oh that's
wonderful you're right i didn't know
about that and like that is one of those
things where like
i immediately see the problematic
elements of that but at the same time i
can't help but admire the audacity of it
like i mean it's it's more of a
confident move than nintendo usually
does
yeah yeah yeah i can't remember the last
time nintendo did something that
that confident yeah it's not a half
measure
definitely definitely certainly not yeah
it's one of those things but birdo is a
trans character like
you know there are arguments to be made
both ways as to is nintendo
you know by not acknowledging that just
retconning that it ever happened other
you know do you want to read it as just
alberto
is just uh being treated as a woman now
by nintendo because you know
what why do we need to keep pointing out
that she's trans i
i think back pedal's probably more
likely considering the whole line in
that manual about would prefer to be
called birdetta and they've not called
her berdeka in any of the future games
would suggest that it's probably an
attempted back pedal but
yeah at least i would hope so because
otherwise nobody has thought of the fact
that we have in paper basically that
everything with berto since then is
canonically dead naming her so
yeah but like i i don't
hate birdo as a trans representation
because i
despite the logistical problems with the
fact that it would have to consistently
mean nintendo's been dead naming her for
decades
i like to quietly be like nintendo were
like yep she's a trans woman and let's
not bring it up needlessly in future
because why is it important
it just is a fact i'd like to think that
that is true i mean that's one of the
that's one of the difficult things about
trans representation in a lot of ways
and
because the thing is is that to to treat
um with binary trans people you know
trans women trans men and not
getting into the non-binary end of it
quite yet
to represent them strictly speaking
any male or female character could be
seen to represent them because they're
just being a man
or woman but it becomes a weird thing
where to make it canonically trans
involves a certain amount of
hanging a lampshade on it that while
helpful in terms of confirming the
representation can often make it a bit
more awkward
than it need be and oftentimes the the
transness of a character becoming a plot
point
when maybe it didn't need to be
yeah and you know there will eternally
be debates about
what is the correct amount of yes this
character is trans before you stop
bringing it up
but there's no there's no easy answers
to that i think that like very clearly
if this was intended to be trans
representation with birdo it was
messily handled to say the least and um
comes with a lot of pitfalls that would
have required a lot of fixing later
but i mean i i
i struggle to feel too negatively
towards nintendo about birdo because
given the the year that this was the
game was released and the fact that like
it was released in japan it it feels
relatively forward-thinking for when it
released
it it does uh now speak
around the same time we also got the
very convoluted case of poison
in final fight yeah yeah
so this is another one of those ones
that's inconsistent depending on your
region
and where you ask um the story goes
that both poison and roxy were
originally trans women because
if they're trans women that means
they're men and you're allowed to beat
them up
yeah it's not okay to it's not okay to
punch a girl but if it's
really a guy that's okay yeah which
the way i feel about poison is that
poison started off from completely the
worst possible justification you could
have for a trans character
but the fact they have stuck with
keeping poison
relatively consistently as a trans
character
and have not done anything too gross or
stereotyped with her presentation
throughout the years has somewhat
leveled out
that a little bit yeah i i mean like
poison's obviously a
incredibly exaggerated hype yeah i
profound hyper sexualized character but
that's
also part and parcel for the genres she
shows up in so she's not exactly
treated differently from anybody else
exactly and i would rather that
than the oh here's the obvious visual
tell of her
of her being trans you know like that
like that's the thing i always worry
about in fighting games with their
exaggerated character designs is
what's the trans character feature
you're going to put in here
yeah where's the where's the five
o'clock shadow where's the bulge what's
yeah what's it gonna be
yeah yeah and like there's there's a lot
of problems with the way that poison was
originally handled like the
original japanese concept art uh
includes a term that loosely translates
as
uh she-male which is not great like it
shows the
mentality that was going on when the
character was originally created
um there's stuff in later years as well
which has muddied the conversation
uh capcom's classics collection um
refers to poison as simply being a
cross-dresser um
so like there are little bits here and
there that muddy
poison as consistent representation
but and again people can disagree with
me on this but i feel like
at the very least poison is nowhere near
as bad a piece of representation as she
started off as
yeah now what's sort of funny about
the early years of representation is
that i feel like it's
probably not unfair to call it in many
ways at least partially accidental
representation because yeah because like
the line of alberto in the manual
feels like it's a joke and the thing
about poison if the story is true
then it was never thought as let's
represent trans people it was let's
work around the fact that otherwise
you're beating up women you have to kind
of get to
more recent times before you start
getting characters who are
who are made trans intentionally as
opposed to accidentally
how much that actually makes it better
seems to vary
uh on a case-by-case basis though yeah
you've definitely got different eras of
trans representation in games like if
you look at the
the 80s into the early 90s um a lot of
it was
introducing trans characters either as a
joke or
to get around some kind of limitation or
as some kind of punch line
um the 2000s you start seeing
trans characters that are introduced but
largely localized out of certain regions
um it's it's very interesting that a lot
of the 2000s trans representation that
was deliberate
is canonical in japan and
basically are raised in in the uk in
america
basically europe usually got to keep
keep that intact
um it's it's very
like some countries in europe were like
act actively made
trans storylines more prominent than
they were in the original japanese which
i find really interesting of that era
it is it is kind of interesting and like
i don't
i don't know enough about the the
japanese culture
to fully wrap my head around this but
like
between this and a couple years ago when
i had a conversation with
em middleton who's non-binary and we
talked about representation
and they brought up a number of anime
and
manga examples some of them quite from
quite a few years ago and just sort of
realizing you know
not without its own problematic elements
but there definitely seems to at least
been
an acknowledgement within japanese
culture of
a lot more gender blending and middle
ground
whereas a lot of western cultures just
want to pretend that that's not even a
thing that exists
you can debate where japan is in terms
of um
rights for actual trans and non-binary
people but
at least in terms of media
representation there was something that
went on in the mid to late 2000s
where the country seemed to
really embrace storytelling about trans
people existing and
it's tough to tell how much of that was
mysterious
and other is a good storytelling tool
and the mystique surrounding that maybe
but
there was a period of time where like
yeah i i
a big part of me like realizing what was
going on with myself and gender was to
do with some manga that released in the
mid to late 2000s from japan
there's a lot of there's several
examples of games that released in that
sort of time and
clearly japan was having some kind of
let's talk about trans people in stories
yeah well yeah
um although you know bringing it a bit
more up to date more in the 2010s
and um and now
you know we get um
that's kind of where you have to come up
to before you start getting
trans people as primary characters as
opposed to
npcs or supporting um
at the very least outside of indie games
which always kind of have the freedom to
do their own thing
but you know you have to come up to
something like 2018 before you get
something like jj mackfield which is
semi-indie it kind of feels like it's
yeah
proper triple a um and i know sweary has
stepped in it since then yes
to put it lightly yes yeah
which it's funny despite the fact that i
don't talk about video games a great
deal on this channel i remember watching
that play out
and feeling like this feels like the
embodiment of the kind of thing i always
caution about when i
talk about you know writing what you
know and doing the research
if you don't know because
without having played either one
personally
but the impression that i was left with
was jj magfield
he he consulted with actual lgbtq and
trans people
got their input on that and you can feel
that in the game and then when it came
to deadly premonition too
seem to think i've got this oh
did it all on his own and yeah what
can i talk about this whole thing for
anyone who's watching this and doesn't
know because i
don't have one okay so there's this game
developer called sweary who released a
cult game
about a decade ago called deadly
premonition uh very inspired by twin
peaks but a very sort of like janky
rough around the edges twin peaks homage
um the game um there's gonna be some
spoilers here
the game features a character who um
for all intents and purposes the game
sort of presents as a cross-dresser or
that seems to be what the text is
implying
who is involved in the murder of lots of
women it's kind of shitty but it's not
explicitly or at least
in the text of the game it didn't seem
to be explicitly trans representation
then sweary goes on and makes jj mcfeels
in the island of memories which
at the time with no later context i very
much praised as
a game it is a short little indie game
um again is it right if i just talk
spoilers because i don't think
about this um it is a story of a trans
woman who
after a lot of um conversion therapy
pressure from her mother and
being outed at her university attempts
to take her own life it is a very heavy
topic
but the point of the game is it is her
going
no actually i want to live i want to
survive i want to get through this i
want to be
me it is about surviving a suicide
attempt and coming out stronger and
going on to live your life um it's very
clear as you said that the game was made
in
consultation with lgbt and specifically
trans uh consultants
uh there's there's some really lovely
stuff towards the end of um
so the titular character jj um toward
the end of the game she is seen by her
girlfriend
lying with her chest flat and her wig
not
on being taken care of by doctors and
her
girlfriend doesn't dead name her or
misgender her she still treats her
exactly as much
of a woman as she did before and like
that's really lovely
there it's it's a it's a rough topic the
game
tackles but it does so with hope and
optimism um
i came out of that game being like it's
very clear that you listened to people
and you made something really good out
of that
everything that comes after jj mcfield
is where sweary
clearly gets the impression that like
aha i'm great at telling trans stories i
don't need any help anymore
um and starts to not only like screw up
his later work
but retroactively make his earlier work
worse
so first of all he does an interview
with i believe it's rely on horror
in which he says that no one is wrong
for being who they are
and that includes jj's mother who
attempted to push her into conversion
therapy
so that's the first red flag that he
does not understand what he's talking
about
then yeah then he goes and retcons
thomas the
sister obsessed woman murderer from
deadly premonition one
to now be canonically a trans woman
right
so okay we move on to deadly premonition
two
he repeats the tropes he used with
thomas but more explicitly he makes
another character who is a sister
obsessed in this case
incestuous woman murdering trans woman
um not only that there's a whole bunch
of problems in that game
with um retroactive dead naming and
misgendering
um any time that the main character
talks about this tran woman
in the past tense he will use a dead
name and
uh wrong pronouns um
there's a lot of
the game has this trans woman character
out and dead name herself
in a conversation um at one point
the the main character uses the correct
pronouns then stops mid-sentence to
correct himself and dead name and
misgender
like he starts and does it correctly and
stops himself in the mid-sentence to
use the wrong information
and the thing that makes this all worse
is before the trans woman character is
introduced
the main character goes on this whole
big rant about how
everyone in the town is transphobic and
he's the only one who respects trans
people like
why would i be bigoted just because
they're transgender i respect everyone
for who they are anyway i'm gonna go
over there and
use your dead name as a gotcha it's
oh it's it's it's bad it's really bad
that's that's the kind of
five-lane pile up disaster of mistakes
that
only happens when you sh when you're
sure
that you've got this and you didn't
check with anybody
yeah oh also he uh cast a cis man to
play
and voice this trans woman because of
course oh yeah
let's just throw that in there while
we're at it yeah it's
after people complained about this he
made a statement saying i'm gonna fix it
i understand everyone's complaints i'm
going to fix it
he took one line of dialogue out of the
game which is the one where the main
character goes aha
gotcha dead name which i mean that's an
improvement but it does mean that
afterwards
the trans characters dead naming
themselves unprompted because
they've not had the gotcha done at them
it's it made it worse in some ways
it's it is it is a
laundry list of everything i tell
developers don't
don't do this and like it wouldn't
even be as bad if he had if it wasn't
like oh you've just done the same thing
you did with
thomas from deadly premonition one
you've made character obsessed with
their sister who
wears women's clothes and murders women
and there's a danger to women
that's apparently what we are when you
don't get consultants in
it it really and what what's so
frustrating is
there's obviously a lot of nuance and
even debate within
with just the trans community saying
nothing about the larger lgbtq plus
community about
the best ways to do representation and
there isn't always agreement
but pretty much everything that you just
named anybody
in the trans community would have said
no don't do that
yeah like i am aware that there is a
debate about what constitutes proper
representation i know for some people
the day when we can have a villainous
trans character and that doesn't feel
weird will be when we reach
representation i get that argument but
like we are not there yet
right now if you make a habit of in two
games in a series in a row going
man in man in dress obsessed with sister
murders women
it's dangerous that looks like a trend
and it looks like it's implying some
shitty stuff about trans people yeah
the the thing that i've that i've
hammered on in
in a few other times is that when i see
the arguments about like well if you
want equality then you shouldn't have a
problem with
a trans villain character or when i've
seen it
um when i've talked about like the
problems with casting cis people
as trans characters or people like but
if you want equality
shouldn't that be okay and then trans
people could play cis characters and my
answer to that is
always like all things being equal
yes but things aren't equal so if you
start pretending
that we have accomplished what we
eventually want now
then all you do is lock in the status
quo
you need to actually bring everybody up
to the same level and then
you can start treating them the same
yeah give us the thing we're not getting
the give us some positive examples and
then maybe we can talk about bringing
that up to match
but i look forward to the day when video
games as a medium can get to the point
where we're not getting uh what was the
headline i saw this week for reya and
the last dragon
has a blink and you'll miss it milestone
of trans representation
that's one trans voice actor does one
line in the background of a scene
like that should not be a news story one
person a trans person did one line in
the background of a disney film
but like when we can get past that as
the state of representation then maybe
we can talk about like
having villainous trans characters and
that not seeming to imply that trans
people are villains
yeah yeah that i look forward to that
day
i don't know if i'll get it in my
lifetime but uh sure would be nice
it sure would be nice
now um what
one of the things that i noted and i
don't know where else to mention this so
i'm just going to bring it up now
because
it's this is something that i've noted
that isn't unique to video games
i've noted this in a lot of things is
that
when and not just trans when queer
representation
shows up in anything designed to be an
ongoing franchise
it's never in the first installment
it always comes later
and with maybe the exception of poison i
so i had to think about this because you
sent some some notes before we started
and the only other example from recent
years i can think of
is uh horizon zero dawn has one trans
man
npc and that is the first game in that
series
but we're up we're up to two yeah we're
up to two
i struggle to think of any others
outside of the indie space
um yeah i very much struggle to think of
any that were not introduced in sequels
and i think that there's an obvious
reason for that which is
testing the waters and making sure
people have brand loyalty so that you
don't scare them away with a trans
character yeah like from a business
perspective i get it and i first started
i first
noticed it actually in like ongoing
fantasy series or young adult series
because
um my partner is uh as a school
librarian so
she would have recommendations you know
this series of that series or
when when any
uh queer or trans ally started looking
for an alternative to harry potter
i would get a lot of suggestions for
other series and
i started to notice and then i started
asking on a regular basis when people
would say oh there's this gender fluid
character there's this lesbian character
that's trans one and i'm like
what what entry in the series were they
brought in
and it was always like uh the second the
third
and i'm like that's that's nice and
and again from a business perspective i
get it but i'm like that's
yeah well i mean like the example i
think of in video games that that
exemplifies this really well
is overwatch which is a video game that
has a lot of canonically lgbt characters
none of whom were confirmed lgbt at the
time of the game's launch
they waited until the game had been out
and been successful and everyone was
enjoying playing it to then in
supplementary outside material go of
that character's uh
that sexuality and that character that
sexuality you know once they already
knew that there was an audience that was
enjoying and playing rather than be like
oh well what if we put them in up front
then maybe people won't buy it oh
yeah i'm gonna make a i'm gonna make a
prediction right here
i think when overwatch 2 originally
eventually releases we're going to get
confirmation one of the heroes is trans
like i have a real gut feeling that they
are ramping up to that but again
for the sequel yeah and i mean like by
that point they
they have a dedicated player base where
even the people who don't like that
yeah the number of them who are going to
stop playing a game they really enjoy
because of that
is exactly pretty low no matter how much
noise they make about it
yeah exactly but it it
yeah you make a very good point most of
the time it is in sequels
so like the other element that is
actually much more unique to video games
um as a because these other sort of
representational things
they come up in any medium film
television books
but there's also the the more unique
element of the ability of uh
players to create custom characters in
some games and then whether or not
the way the character creation is
designed allows for
more gender-bending options or not
which obviously it came up recently with
hogwarts legacy
yeah and i remember when i was thinking
about that you know
when i heard basically at least my
understanding of what they were doing
which was basically
um removing restrictions in terms
of what could be what um honorifics
could be paired with what kind of
character build and and
things along those lines wow
all we explicitly know about hogwarts
legacy or at least from the uh the the
the report that happened was that your
voice
uh and body type can be independently
selected so you can be a feminine body
type with a deep voice for example
um and you can pick which of the two
binary dormitories to be placed into
regardless of your
body type or voice yeah which is is not
much
but sort of where i was going is that
when i looked at that i remember
thinking
that's kind of the literal bare minimum
because it requires no uniquely authored
content
all you have to do is remove
restrictions yes
so i i really wanted to talk about this
because like
hogwarts legacy is a really great
example of um
the problems with doing this because uh
the the report that i believe was on
bloomberg about this
explicitly labeled this as a trans
character creator
and it i have a lot of problems with
labeling it that way because what that
actually is is a gender non-conforming
character generally yeah
i would i would call it non-binary
creation more than i would call it
yeah or at least because to most people
you say the word trans they think trans
man trans woman
even though it is an umbrella term yeah
that's not what people default to when
they hear it
this is clearly not a non-binary
character creator because you still have
to go in the witch or the wizard dorm
and those are still very very gendered
and
it's it's one of these things we saw it
with cyberpunk 2777 as well which was
um hey you can put a deep voice with a
feminine character
that's trans you can put a feminine
voice on a deep character that's trans
um cyberpunk an even worse example of
this because they tied your pronouns to
your choice of voice tone so
if you picked a low voice no matter what
else you did
you were getting he him pronouns like
how
i don't understand how you can have a
system like that and go yep that's trans
character creator
right there like it's very clear that
with this and with hogwarts legacy no
trans person was involved who could stop
in and say
i mean that's really simplifying the
whole thing and you should maybe think
about it a bit more
yeah and it kind of comes back to what
we said earlier which is that
to to call that trans representation
is to say that we're talking about
feminine men or masculine
women yeah whereas like no we're just
talking about men and women and then it
becomes the weird thing of
well like how do how do you build a
trans
character that is acknowledged as trans
because for a lot of trans people it
would just be creating a female
character creating a male character
yeah and huh
i the thing that
if you're going to have a character
creator and you're going to say this is
a trans character creator what i hear
when i hear that is oh
maybe i'll meet a trans character at
some point in game and i'll get offered
a unique line of dialogue that i get to
say because i made my character trans
like something like that feels like okay
some kind of
ability to opt into acknowledging you've
made a trans character maybe
or some kind of acknowledgement in game
because if you just
give gender non-conforming character
options and then just
have the game play out completely as
usual
yeah there is nothing inherently trans
about that character other than what you
as the player have imagined into it
yourself
yeah and while i don't want to overstate
the value of that i certainly would like
to see more
authored content on that note i do still
find it interesting
how at least from what i could find how
infrequent the ability to even do
that indeed is yeah as
as critical as i'm being here of like
labeling that a trans character creator
it's wonderful when that's an option
because that opens up
a lot more people to being able to
create a character that looks and sounds
like themselves and that's great that's
a wonderful thing
but it's it's such an easy thing that
like
in most games you're going to get zero
pushback for giving people the option to
pick from all of the voices and all of
the uh body types and all of the outfits
that is just most people will will just
pick
design their binary character that looks
like them and that's fine
but but by not segmenting stuff away to
be gender specific
you open up the ability for people to
represent themselves and that's
that's great that's wonderful it's such
an easy win
the i'm surprised isn't just something
that is becoming a standard
yeah that's sort of my thing with with
the hogwarts thing like i said it
it again calling it trans representation
is
a bit of a thing but like i do find
myself wondering
why is that not the standard
and like i i get it when it's not meant
to be a blank slate character and they
are
um you know meant to have a specific
personality where
you know something like assassin's creed
syndicate where we have two specifically
authored character one male 1 female
pick one i'm like i
i get that but if you're empowering us
to build our own character
wouldn't the selling point be to give us
as many
options as possible more choice is
always a good thing
no one's ever going to complain you gave
them too much choice
yeah and like i i st this is
probably the most recently made game
that i've actually played
was i played shovel knight recently and
i had played the game all the way
through before i actually started
fiddling around with the options and
realized that i could change not only
the pronouns that
my character was referred to as but the
pronouns for
shield knight who is the love interest
character
and like it and again that doesn't
really make it trans but it does
it's just a simple change in text and
it's so easy
to to implement and to make available
why wouldn't you just have that it's so
easy to make a tiny change that
allows a player to go oh i can see
myself slightly more in this now
i feel better about this game i'm a
bigger fan of it now as a result like
it's such an easy win
it is and and i mean
and one of the things that's that's
frustrating i said we wouldn't dwell too
much on the
reaction from the outside world to these
but i i couldn't help but get this stuck
in my head
today one of the things that's really
frustrating when people
with the kinds of people who tend to
kick up a stink about
when these things are even available as
an option
are so often the same sorts of people
who will defend
something like grand theft auto where
you have the option to kill
prostitutes but it's not a misogynistic
game because it's not required by the
game that's an
option so it's not misogynistic but
giving an
option to be gender non-conforming
that that's not okay to even be optional
that shouldn't be there at all
now it's agenda pushing yeah
i i did want to know one game that does
really well
handle trans character creation that i
think is like the
the the one that i think does it for a
reason and handles it really
uh efficiently and doesn't make it a big
deal uh and i think it's one that you
had a list on this list is the sims
4 does a really really good job so for
anyone who's not played it um
the sims 4 allows for you to create
characters and you you
it works in minor agenda terms still but
you pick a you pick a gender but then
you get to answer questions such as
cam your can your sim get pregnant can
your sim
key standing up uh questions that are
important
to what functionally your character can
do and that can help you build out a
character that's like okay
i have a masculine presenting character
who can get pregnant
and that that is a thing that the game
you know supports and it's there for a
game play reason and it's never made a
big deal it's just
this is what my character looks like
this is biologically what they are
capable of
and that's really nice simple efficient
like
that that's the example i point to for
trans character creation
that's really great and it's like my
brain just went through a little thing
because part of it when
it's funny that i don't remember there
being a stink about this but then i
thought like oh well the audience for a
game like the sim
is not the audience that would make a
deal out of this being included the kind
of people who would get upset about this
don't play the sims
and the people who play the sims are
usually the kind of people who love
being able to tweak and really like
get the nitty-gritty granular details of
what they want their
universe to be like yeah oh that's oh
that's wonderful though
yeah it's it's such a simple
implementation that like i
obviously not every video game needs to
know if you're
if your um fem presenting character can
pee standing up
but like for this specific game it's a
really good handling event
that's oh that's great
i suppose the one other thing is that i
at this point at least from what i could
find it does seem that
outside of indie games um because you
know again the the lack of oversight
they can they can do whatever they like
it does seem like we have yet to get a
player character who is
trans in a in what is intended to be a
larger mainstream game
which i i have mixed feelings about
because on the one hand
you know we can look at someone like
what's going on with sweary and go
okay if they're not going to get the
consultation
maybe it's good that they're not trying
to put that front and center
but at the same time you know as i'm
starting to see
um player characters become
more diverse in other areas more diverse
in terms
of sexual orientation in terms
of race in terms of
mental status and neurodivergency and
things like that to see
that trans is still very much regular uh
relegated to
supporting characters npcs
is still a little bit like we're gonna
be the last ones to
to get to be the main characters aren't
we we are
and i think that at least in part that
is probably because of the fact that
there are still
several countries in which it is illegal
to be trans
i think that like the knowledge that
like your big budget
aaa game will not be allowed to be sold
in certain countries is going to be
a decision that gets factored in for a
while yeah
but even so i think just
trans people's existence is currently a
cultural battleground
and it's being fought over pretty pretty
intensely and i think there's probably a
lot of boardrooms of
game developers who are saying now's not
the time
because what if the the side of history
that this lands on is that the
anti-trans people win
and you know like i feel like there is
we don't want to touch this because it's
a hot button issue i think is
probably the feeling going around well i
mean there's
it as it gets noted on the podcast you
do with um
with jim stephanie sterling he gets
noted rather regularly like oh
we are going to pretend there's no
politics in this game
and at present the existence of trans
people has become a political
issue if you have a trans main character
you can't pretend you're not politics
right now
yes but like i i think
we're heading towards it i would hazard
just
i i would have to say
by the time the next console generation
rolls around
in like five to seven years i would be
surprised if
it if it hasn't already happened that
like we
it does that it will feel like the time
i reckon i reckon by the time that the
playstation 6 or whatever rolls around
i think we will probably have seen
someone try
i i'd like to hope that i think that
i think that we're in the five six seven
years in which
the conversation's gonna get over that
hill hopefully and we become less of a
political statement to exist
but that's a lot of hope in that
well i mean that doesn't seem like a
complete because we are already getting
steps as much as it's a
game that just even looking at the
trailers immediately turned me off and i
wasn't interested
it is worth noting that something like
the last of us part two
had a trans character as prominently as
it did
and again like it it depends what you
consider triple a because like last year
we had uh tell me why which obviously
was a narrative driven
um adventure game it's not a traditional
you know aaa but a budget title but it
is a
big name studio making a game where you
had a playable trans man as the
as as one of the two playable main
characters
like we're getting to the point where a
lot of aaa franchises are playing around
with
let's have our one token trans npc and
they're not always doing it well and
they're not always terribly prominent
but
they're at least going let's put a trans
character in the game and
see how people feel about it um i think
i think what we'll probably see even
within this generation possibly
is that a a sub
aaa developer um
you know not totally indie but someone
who
doesn't have their own publishing arm
and needs to rely on a publisher
may make the leap on a mid-budget game
to do that
that a larger publisher will take the
chance to release on because they've got
less
liability if they didn't sync the
development money into it
yeah like i could see um possibly
i could see microsoft stepping in and
putting the money behind
something of that degree because like
microsoft um published
tell me why and i feel like microsoft is
the kind of people who would put money
behind lifting something like that up at
the moment
um i could theoretically see one of the
big name indies doing
doing something like the the mike
bithells or someone like that sort of
like
the upper end of like they've got a
budget indies doing stuff
um oh i could see devolver digital doing
it but i'm afraid they do it as a troll
so i i think devolver
knows when not to [ __ ] around like i
i feel like devolver knows enough to not
[ __ ] around with trans people's identity
maybe i'm completely off base there but
my gut says that they probably wouldn't
[ __ ] with it they seem to
they seem to be very aware of internet
discussions and what people think and i
i feel like they would know enough to
not make that misstep
i would hope i mean that it's
it is nice when you at least have the
room for optimism
yeah and and hopefully don't have that
shut down by reality in the future
yeah like i i think the more
the more normalized it becomes to see
trans npcs in games i think that's going
to
inevitably lead to a playable trans
character in a triple-a game and
this might be a case of something like
um the last of us left behind where we
found out that ellie was
um was was gay in a
dlc sequel that came later like i think
we might get a game where you play
through the entire game and then in a
dlc
later or a sequel you get told that
character you are playing as his trans
maybe or we might get we might get our
trans equivalent to samus iran
yeah where like where that first metroid
game you had no idea you were playing a
woman unless you beat it and she took
her helmet off
yeah i i feel like that's probably gonna
be the first
there is a good chance or a better than
no chance that the first time this
happens it is a
surprise at the end of the game or later
like aha you were trans all along
which could could go either way but i i
wouldn't be shocked if that's
if that's how it starts out yeah
um i feel like we're kind of arriving at
a natural conclusion but
before we head off i do actually want to
say that my
favorite piece of what i consider to be
trans representation in gaming
is non-canonical and it's your idea
which is rabid peach oh
should i talk about rabid peach for a
minute please please
so the official rabbids instagram
account
uh for the longest time was just at
rabbids and
it was a bunch of you know weekly or so
meme images of just generic uh standard
rabbit
and you know a lot of the memes were
like i hate being in my suit and tie for
work
every week and all that sort of thing
and then
as they were gearing up to announce
mario and rabbids um
something happened on the the twitter
account where um
so it didn't originally get renamed to
rabbid peach that happens a bit later
but you start getting images
of a feminine rabbid on this account who
like appears to be like slowly getting
more and more femme as the images go
um and there's this whole little if you
go and look at the twitter
this this instagram account from its
oldest post is through to newest
you will see like a storyline develop
for a little while
where it sure as hell seems like very
shy nervous rabid
uh you know he's like hey what if i was
a little what if i was a little bit
oh you will support me i'm fam um
so i am very much of the belief that
like the change from the rabbids twitter
account into becoming the rabid peach
uh instagram account i keep saying
twitter um
is the story of of rabid peach coming
out
and they have yet to delete any of the
older posts so my
my my little narrative still exists and
no one can tell me i'm wrong
i i absolutely love that i mean that was
that was one of the first things you did
that really really came onto my radar
seeing your piece of that i'm like this
is amazing
it's it's clearly not intended to be
representation but no one can tell me
i'm wrong you cannot deny the facts are
there you can go look at them
this is very clearly uh i hate i hate my
suit and tire hey
uh hey i hate who i am oh now i'm a very
happy rabbit with with long hell
look at that i love that and i wanted to
give you the chance to talk about it
because i adore that i
love that to death yeah i will never be
convinced that i'm wrong on that fact
i don't i don't care if you come at me
with facts and logic
you can't you can't tell me that's not
right
i'm i'm right there with you so well
i want to thank you so much for for your
time
and you obviously have a cavalcade of
things where people can find your other
stuff
care to offer some plugs yep uh you can
find me at laura kbuzz on twitter
twitch youtube patreon is the one that
pays my bills
um i twitch stream mondays wednesdays
and fridays at 10 p.m uk
5 p.m eastern 2 p.m pacific uh every
friday on youtube i upload episodes of a
show called access
ability which is all about accessibility
and representation in the games industry
if you want to hear more in-depth
thoughts about my feelings about sweary
and trans representation i did like a
35-minute video about that and
which i go into excruciating detail
which you can go find
um other than that i've got books uh
there's a book called
uncomfortable labels that's out now
which is about living at the
intersection of being an autistic trans
woman
i have a video game book called things i
learned from mario's butt
which is an illustrated coffee table
book of video game character butt
reviews
um i managed to convince a lot of people
in the games industry
it convinced game developers to talk
about the butts of their characters it
was great you should go read it it's
got a wonderful illustration of poison's
ass
um i've got another book coming out on
june 10th
2021 called gender euphoria which is an
anthology of non-cis people's
real life positive gender affirming
stories it's just
a book full of people being happy that
they're not cis
and i needed to write that and i hope
that people enjoy reading it i also do
podcasts um
podquisition we tell you whether your
favorite video games are great or
perfect
uh queer unpleasant strangers where me
and my fiance two queer trans ladies
talk about bits of media we've consumed
during the week and do silly voices and
skits
uh and then there's dice funk which is a
dungeons and dragons podcast
um i'm on seasons three through eight
every season is its own self-contained
story so you can just jump into any
particular season
and start start enjoying there
i think that's everything i i think
we've given people enough stuff to check
out and again thank you
so much for for coming on i really
appreciate it thank you for having me
i just want to thank laura once more for
donating her time to speak to me about
this topic it's something i've wanted to
cover for ages and it was wonderful to
get to speak with her
i hope you'll check out her work and
some of her published stuff and also
a special thanks and reminder to check
out forever home friends the sponsor for
this
video links are down in the description
please check them out
what are your thoughts on this topic
whatever they are
drop something down the comments and
let's talk about it i also have a
patreon
that is what pays the bills hopefully
there was a link that shows up there if
they're not because
youtube's been stupid lately there's a
link for that down in the description as
well all sorts of links down there for
you to check out
but even if you're not able to do that
like share subscribe
that helps me out a great deal spreads
the channel and gets
more people involved in the sorts of
things i like to talk about
but no pressure at the end of the day
you are the council and i am just
running the meetings
until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
don't